That was back in the late 90's, and
what was really cool was this holistic
notion of, of the human motion.
We also didn't have a large database.
You have a small number of,
of examples, so
it's not sort of the large
discriminative database learning kind of
stuff that goes on in
action recognition now.
What we're going to do next time is,
we're going to take a look at
a different approach that takes some,
look at, looks at videos as a time
series, time series analysis.
And just some basic
approach to doing that.
And again, this will be something where
much like the SVM's that we just talked
about, we said we can only give
you a sm, small taste of it, and
if you want to know about it, you should
take the course in machine learning.
We're going to show you a very simple
notion of a form of a graphical
model approach to doing
action recognition, and
if you want to do more that that,
again, you'll take machine learning.
But that's what we're
going to do next time.